[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM CARPENTER: Hi everybody.
My name's Adam Carpenter and
I lead the developer growth
consulting initiative
at Google Play.
For anyone who's not
familiar with it,
what growth consulting does
is take all the data and all
the insights that we have
here at Google, blends them
with my own team's
expertise from industry,
and we leverage that to
help identify opportunities
in each of your games
and apps businesses.
It's an incredibly
rewarding role
because it allows me to
provide a lot of guidance
and a lot of insights that
can help you identify what's
the lowest hanging fruit
in your businesses,
and where's the biggest
opportunity for growth
and improvement.
Additionally, I also work
closely with our product
and engineering
teams to both provide
guidance about what
kind of messaging
we're sharing that resonates
best with developers,
as well as provides
a lot of feedback
based on what developers
are telling us they need
or would provide the
best business advantages.
And today, I'm lucky
to be joined on stage
with three of our experts.
Corina, who's one of the lead
engineers on our console team's
benchmarking project, Fergus,
who's one of the primary PMs
responsible for
benchmarking in vitals,
and Tom who's been instrumental
with our core metrics
opportunities.
Over the next 30 minutes or so,
I'm going to talk about some
of the frameworks that I'd
like to leverage when I think
about business growth and
understanding game and app
performance, and
additionally, my colleagues
are going to share some
of the new features
in tooling that we
implement in the console
that you'll be able to leverage
to understand how your game
or app is performing,
understand what good looks like,
and understand where you could
potentially optimize and grow
your businesses.
All of us are very,
very passionate
about business growth,
and it's really exciting
to be here today.
When I think about
ecosystems, it's
an exceptionally broad concept,
because at the highest level,
you have this concept of games,
you have this concept of apps,
and they're so vastly different.
And even when you begin to look
at what apps are themselves,
we have a whole
host of categories,
we have genres
within categories.
And if you think about apps
like New York Times, Snap,
[INAUDIBLE],, Waze,
CNN, each of them
is fundamentally different
in terms of how they operate.
The value that they provide
to users, the types of metrics
that they look at, and
potentially even the north
stars that they aim for.
But despite all of
those differences,
there are commonalities
across all of them.
The low level,
fundamental metrics
that each app looks at,
that's a commonality that we
can actually understand.
We can see here at
Google, and therefore it
enables us to actually
build tooling around
that to provide better
opportunity identification
and guidance to your
fellow developers,
so that you're better
equipped to understand
how you're performing.
And so whenever I think
about business growth,
especially when I'm working
with a new developer,
I always like to construct
a hierarchical model, which
looks at what does
the developers top
level goal, and what
are all the KPIs,
or all the metrics
that feed up into it?
It's a little bit of
an engineering mindset,
and for me, it comes from
being a chemical engineer.
The way I think
about engineering,
it's, take a problem,
break it down
into all of its core components,
understand how all of them
work, understand how
all of them interrelate
and, by gaining
that understanding,
you can build it back
up to a full solution.
And so the key opportunity
to optimize your business,
no matter how complex
it is, is understanding
how all of these components and
all these facets fit together.
And so in terms
of consultations,
being able to look
at this allows
me to better
understand the business
and be able to support its
growth and continued success
over time.
And to give you a
concrete example of this,
I'll talk about something
that I think is universally
applicable to
everybody in this room,
and it's thinking
about the audience
of your game or your app.
And in the context of
this discussion, what
I mean by audience, I'm
really talking about all
of the Android users around the
entire globe who have your game
or your app installed.
And if you think
about that audience,
you can start to break it apart
into two different sections.
The first being
your active users.
Whether your most
meaningful unit of time
is daily, weekly,
or monthly, who
are those users that are
coming back at that frequency?
And on the opposite
side, then you
have all of those users who've
churned out of your app.
They haven't been active
in the recent past,
but they do still have it
installed on their device,
so they do make up
your audience portion.
And then each of these, you
can decompose even further.
Your active users,
this is largely
the new users who are coming
into your app or your game
for the very first time each
day, or the returning users,
your regular users
who are coming back
on a frequent basis.
And on the flip
side, when we think
about those churned users,
it's really important
to understand what's potentially
driving them out of the game.
What kind of technical
performance issues
are maybe causing a
poor user experience,
causing them to leave the app?
What our team has been
doing is working really
hard to uncover a lot
of these insights,
expose them into the
console to enable you all
to make better
business decisions,
and to tell us a lot more about
what we're actually building,
and what you'll be
able to get access to.
I'd like to welcome Tom to talk.
TOM GRINSTED: Thanks Adam.
[APPLAUSE]
Good afternoon, everyone.
As said, my name is Tom,
I'm a product manager.
I specialize in core
metrics, so these
are really, really fundamental,
foundational metrics
of your app and game businesses.
These are things like
installs and uninstalls, user
acquisition, and user churn.
Now Adam, I just love
how your brain works.
I love this kind of model.
I used to be an app
developer and we
used to use these to
really understand how we
could optimize our businesses.
But any model like this is
only as useful as the data
that you plug into it, because
it's a great way of thinking,
but to make it work for you,
you need fantastic metrics.
Now when I look at this, I can
already see parts of the model
that frankly, the Play
Console right now is not
great at giving you data for.
Returning users, for instance.
Today, you can't get returning
user data in the console,
and that's a problem.
It's a problem because the app
ecosystem has evolved and moved
on.
When we look at global data,
we see that, on average,
between 20% and
25% of all installs
are returning installers.
These are people who have
installed you before,
uninstalled, and decided
to give you a second go.
That's an average as well.
So for some of you,
that percentage
is going to be
much, much higher.
If you want to understand
your active users
and how you acquire
users, you need
to understand these
kind of metrics.
That's why teams in London have
been working for the last two
years to redefine and
completely redevelop
some of our base metrics.
And we've been doing it
so we can get all of you
the information you need
to make better decisions.
I want to explain how
we've approached it.
Deep down, we aim to make our
new metrics understandable,
predictable, more
granular, and more useful.
And they all start
with one of two things.
Do you really want to
measure users, people,
and by users at the moment we
mean signed in Google users
to Play, so one of
the most useful system
identifiers on the web.
Or are you looking for
devices, like Android IDs?
That's the beginning
of our new metrics,
but it's nowhere near the end,
because the next thing we want
to enable you to do
is to decide if you
want to find out
if you've acquired
or lost a user or device.
Have they installed you or
have they uninstalled you?
But then after that we want
to give you more information.
So with our new
metrics set, you'll
be able to choose
whether you're measuring
literally every person, only new
users, or only returning users.
You'll also be able to decide
what you're actually counting.
Are you counting
uniques, individual users
and individual devices?
Or are you counting events,
every time something
happens, so every time a
device is acquired or not?
Or are you counting
actives, who actually
has you installed right now?
And then lastly,
we want to make it
much easier, especially
for the business decision
makers amongst you, to be able
to aggregate this data in ways
that match your
business cadence.
So our new metrics
are going to be
available from
hourly up to calendar
quarterly granularities.
And if you're selecting
uniques, we're
going to deed you over
those times as well.
This is giving you
a level of insight
into what people are doing,
how they're acquiring you,
and if they're churning out that
we've not been able to give you
before, but one that you
absolutely need and we
understand that.
All of these are going to be
available across the dimensions
that we already provide,
so by device, by country,
by app version, and also by
a couple of new ones as well.
My favorite is install method,
because Play can report
on things that
sometimes others can't.
So we're going to start telling
you which of your installs
are pre-installed,
organically came through Play,
were via peer to peer, or other
acquisition methods as well.
So, if you imagine that one
day your VP comes up to you
and she asks how many times you
uninstalled on a specific day,
you can easily
answer that question
by configuring your metrics.
You can look at how
many devices you
lost on a day, and
your major events.
But similarly, let us
imagine that she asked,
how many users did you
win back last month?
Something that we've never
been able to give you
insight on before.
Well with the new metric
sets you can predictably
answer that as well.
So you can select, well,
I'm interested in returning
users acquired, unique
for the last month.
This is how simple
and how clear we want
to make these complex metrics.
And it's also worth
saying that all of these
subscribe to very stringent
user privacy as well.
So we're doing this within
the bounds of Android
strong privacy models.
Now we've taken the way to
think about these metrics
and we've instituted it
directly into the stats page.
This is one of the most powerful
metrics page on the console.
So, just like today, you'll
be able to select up to two
metrics that you can compare.
But then, we
instituted the model
that I just spoke you through.
So you'll be able to select
whether you're looking at new
or returning users or devices.
You'll also be able to
choose whether you're
measuring events or uniques.
Similarly, you'll be able
to choose the granularity,
[INAUDIBLE] over, and you'll
be able to apply new metrics
calculations.
You'll be able to look at
just the parental data,
the cumulative data from
the beginning of time,
or 30 day rolling averages
to really help you
remove noise and spot trends.
Now these metrics
can be complex.
We hope they're
really, really helpful,
but after you found the
one that you really want,
and one that you want
to come back to again
and again and again,
we want to make it easy
for you to use that.
So the stats page is also going
to have suggestive reports,
and saved reports as well.
These allow you to
quickly jump to the things
that you're looking
for, and even
name them in a way
that's sensible to you.
As you can see, I quite
like using my emojis.
Now, we've been working on
this for ages, and all of them
are going to be launched over
the next couple of months.
ADAM CARPENTER: So this
type of data can really
or power the type of insights
that I was talking about.
And a lot of the developers
we've been testing it with
have been really excited
about what it's enabled.
And like Francesco
from [INAUDIBLE]
it's really amazing to see how
developers can take advantage
of the types of
information we're
able to present in the console.
But it's one of these
things that like--
more data is good,
but data by itself
isn't necessarily as meaningful.
What developers really need as
business leaders and decision
makers is data in context,
which is really information,
because information can
actually empower leaders to make
meaningful business
decisions that will actually
result in a positive impact.
TOM GRINSTED: Right, no,
I completely get that.
The data is the beginning
of your understanding,
but it's not the end.
One of the things
that we've done
is talk to a lot of developers
about common modes of analysis
that you also do with
Play data, and we're
baking some of those
analyses directly
into the product as well.
So if we scroll down
the new statistics page,
you can find my favorite
chart on the console
at the moment, the brand
new change analysis chart.
What this does is
takes the dimension
you've selected
for your metrics,
the beginning of your period,
and the end of your period,
and nets the difference.
Basically, it's a
really quick, easy way
to see which were the biggest
movers over a period of time.
So in this example,
which countries change
most with my active users.
It's a really quick,
simple way to understand
what the data is
trying to tell you,
and what the data tells
you is really telling you
what Android users are
trying to tell you,
which is how they acquire and
how they churn out of your app.
ADAM CARPENTER:
And this is great
because this is something
that you all, if inclined,
could work into the type
of hierarchical model
that I was discussing before.
And it's important to
actually really see,
how can you leverage the value
that Google provides to better
understand your business?
But to be a bit blunt,
Tom, it's one thing
to see your own performance,
but this is only half the story
because, while developers can
benchmark against themselves
and try to guess at
how you're doing,
maybe relative to your
own mallet tricks,
maybe relative one
of your other apps,
it would be much more powerful
if developers could actually
see how they compared
against their top peers.
TOM GRINSTED: Right,
I completely get that,
and thanks for being blunt.
Your data is always
useful to you.
But context is even more
useful, because context
helps you understand
what your data looks
like compared to a
much, much broader
ecosystem of information.
Now this leads us on
to what I think is
an amazing, fantastic product.
I could talk about it
for ages, but I'm not
the best person to do
so, because Corina here
has been leading
our teams working
on ecosystem benchmarks.
So I'd like to hand over to
her to tell you all about it.
[APPLAUSE]
CORINA GRIGORAS: Thanks Tom.
Hi everyone.
I'm Corina and I'm an
engineer on the Play Console.
So I'll tell you about
some of the great insights
you can get from benchmarks.
Now, as Adam and Tom
mentioned, imagine
you're trying to assess
how your app is doing.
So go into Play Console,
and you look, for instance,
at your user acquisition
and your user loss.
If this is what you see, what
do these graphs tell you?
Well, your user
acquisition is going up,
so that's good, right?
That means you're doing well.
But your user loss
is also going up.
So what does that mean?
Maybe that's not so good,
because you'd ideally
want to retain users
and not lose them.
This is where benchmarks can
be very useful, because they
can add context to
these numbers and help
you evaluate these trends.
Now let's look at
your performance
if we compare it
next to a benchmark.
In this case, you can see that
your acquisition is not only
doing well, it's actually
doing really well,
because your acquisition
is going upwards,
even though the benchmark
is going downwards.
This means you're doing
much better in this area.
So it's a good reason for
you to celebrate and probably
not invest or focus too much.
And for user loss, you also
see a positive sign this time,
because even though
it is going upwards,
It's doing so at a slower
rate than the benchmark.
And this is where I find
that benchmarks can give you
really interesting insights.
What this probably
means is that there
is limited opportunity in
the market in this area,
because the trend
that you see, it's
common to the wider market.
And it's not something
that is specific to Europe.
So in this example,
you can see how
benchmarks help you get an
overall positive picture
of your performance.
But now, imagine that
your performance is still
exactly the same, and
the benchmark instead
look like this.
In this case, your
acquisition is going upwards,
but it's doing so at a slower
rate than the benchmark.
Now the difference might
be pretty tiny today,
but if this trend continues,
that difference will increase.
So you probably want
to monitor this area
and start thinking about
how you can address it.
And this time, your user loss
is actually not doing that well,
because your user
loss is going upwards,
but the benchmark is going
downwards in this area.
This shows that there's a
big opportunity here for you,
and a lot of headroom
for improvement.
And this is exactly what
benchmarks highlight
in these examples, the areas
with opportunity in the market,
and how large these
opportunities are.
So it can hopefully help
you prioritize the things
you want to focus on next.
But there's one
challenge in benchmarks.
Comparing absolute numbers
of acquisition and loss
might not always be the right
or the best thing to do.
To address this
issue, we're also
working on calculating
change rates.
Change rates are
relative differences
of a metric from one
period to the next.
We will calculate this on all
of the metric configurations
that Tom mentioned earlier.
And we will also add benchmarks
to all of these change rates.
And hopefully, with
all these additions,
we'll be able to give you better
context on how your app grows
over time, but also a
meaningful comparison that you
can use to assess that growth.
So when all this is
available, here's
an example of the kind
of insight and analysis
you'll be able to get
from the Play Console.
For instance, you'll be able
to compare how quickly you're
acquiring users, or
you'll be able to check
if your uninstall rates
are abnormally high,
or even compare how your
growth performs versus
the benchmark in
specific countries
or in some specific devices.
ADAM CARPENTER: So
benchmarks are really cool,
but they're only as valuable
as a set of peers you
have to compare yourself with.
It's a little bit like
garbage in, garbage out.
What are we doing
to give developers
more actionable insights?
CORINA GRIGORAS: I think
that's a great point,
and that's where I personally
find benchmarks really
exciting, because
what we have done
is used all the understanding
and the metadata
that Play has about the apps
and games that we published,
and with all of this,
we have automatically
generated curated peer sets.
These are essentially
sets of apps
that have very
similar functionality,
and you can use
one of these sets
to compare your
performance against.
And we even recommend
the set that we
think are most suitable
for your app or game
to be compared with.
We will compute benchmarks
for all of these peer sets,
and we will do so with very
strong privacy protection
so no individual app
or game metrics will
be able to be reverse engineered
from the benchmark value
that we show in the console.
And we'll have a total of over
150 peer sets, and these range
very much, from racing
games to wallpaper apps,
or from social apps
to streaming media.
So you'll be able to
compare your growth
to a benchmark performance
computed on a very wide range
of these curated peer sets.
ADAM CARPENTER: And so
this is kind of great,
and what we found is that
the developers who've
been able to access this
early on or get hints
about and provide feedback
are already seeing ways
that they can use this
to power decision making,
to be able to run
better experiments,
and it feels like, as valuable
as this is what you're talking
about, it'd also
be really useful
if we were to integrate it
back into some of the reporting
that we already
have, the acquisition
report we launched last year.
CORINA GRIGORAS: Yeah,
that's an excellent point,
and that's exactly
what we intend to do.
We intend to bring curated
peer sets to the acquisition
reports.
Now, what acquisition
reports show
you today is a
benchmark that's only
computed on a peer set that
represents the same place
or category as your app or game.
And this is good when you're
looking for that broad market
comparison, but it might be a
bit limiting if you're looking
for a more specific comparison.
One example that we
hear a lot from you devs
is around the maps and
navigation category.
This navigation contains
navigation apps, taxi and ride
sharing apps, train timetable
apps, public transportation
apps, and so on.
And as you can see, these
vary widely in functionality.
Now if you're in this
category and are looking
to compare with
your competitors,
you probably want to dig a bit
deeper than the category level.
With curated peer
sets, we have created
a hierarchical structure,
so they will easily
allow you to switch between
the broad market comparison
and the more specific one.
And what's even more exciting
is, whenever it's possible,
we're going to let you narrow
this down even further.
But Fergus is going
to be talking more
about this in a few minutes.
ADAM CARPENTER: This
is really very cool.
When can the developers
get their hands on it?
CORINA GRIGORAS: All
this will be available
soon in the console, in
the next month or two.
So stay tuned for
our announcement.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM CARPENTER: Thanks Corina.
These are insights that
are really, really powerful
and something I'm really
excited to see being pushed out
into the console because,
while my team does
work that I really,
really enjoy, there's only
a small number of
us, and everything
we can do in the console,
it's available and accessible
to everybody in this
room and every developer
around the world.
And I really love how
all of these insights,
especially once
you can benchmark
your app against
the basket of peers,
it's going to really
contextualize your performance
and seriously help you
understand what good actually
looks like.
And what I'm hoping
is that you guys
are going to be able
to get to the point
where you can develop really
actionable insights based
on what you're able to see,
and really be much more
informed about what
good looks like
and what your performance is.
And so, if you think back
about this mall that I'm
talking about, the addressable
audience, and the data that Tom
was talking about,
it should really
help you actually understand
user acquisition, user loss,
who's active on any given
day, who's actually returning.
And one of the neat
things is that these
are all free benefits you
get from publishing on Play.
And it's one of those
things that is exciting
to me, working at Google,
is that we can actually
expose a lot of this to you.
But if you think about this
model that we're talking about,
primarily we've been focusing
on that left side of the tree,
and the right side
is equally important,
in some ways even
more important,
because negative performance,
poor user experiences,
all of these can drive
users out of the game.
And if you're an
app or a game that
does paid user
acquisition, you've
already spent a lot of
money to get the mints.
The last thing you want to
do is actually lose them.
And so, I think to understand
a lot of that side of the tree,
you're going to want much
more control about who
your competitors are,
who's in the peer set,
and I need to get Fergus
to talk about some
of the really neat things we're
doing to give you a much more
intelligent view of your
vitals, and how you're
comparing to competitors.
FERGUS HURLEY: Well Adam,
as the app ecosystem
has become more and
more competitive,
your app's technical performance
has actually become one
of its most important features.
When we look at the
Google Play reviews,
we can see that app
tech on performance
has a direct impact
on your ratings.
Here you can see that
42% of the reviews
are talking about bugs
and stability alone.
And that's why we built Android
vitals into the Play Console.
Android Vitals provides you
over 10 engineering performance
metrics, so you can
be able to understand
how your app is performing
across five performance areas.
Now, I was the founding product
manager of Android vitals,
and as part of that, I
worked with many experts
across Google to invent
these new metrics.
One of the things we
struggled with when
we gave these metrics to
our early access partners
for that program
was that they didn't
know whether this
metric was good or bad,
and that's why, when we first
launched Android vitals two
years ago, we introduced it with
the concept of bad behaviors.
This is where we flagged
the bottom 25% of apps
as having a bad behavior.
So you knew if you had to
improve your performance.
Last year, at Google I/O,
we went one step further
and we introduced
category benchmarks,
so you were able to understand
what percentage of apps
in every category
you were better than,
and so you could
be able to invest
your resources in the areas that
you needed to improve the most.
App categories are
pretty important,
and there are major differences
between app categories,
as you can see here as an
example of slow cold start
times.
However, as Corina
mentioned, app categories
are oftentimes too
broad, and that's
why we're really excited
to have curated peer sets.
Now, we want to go
one step further.
Hands up here, who
has ever wanted
to be able to compare
their technical performance
with their direct competitors?
OK, good stuff, that's very
much everyone for everyone
who's on the videos.
We're extremely excited, and I
am personally extremely proud,
to be able to announce
today, developer
selected peer benchmarks.
This enables you to be able to
select your direct competitors
that you want to be able to
compare your performance with.
And when you do that, you
can be able to then see
the peer median for that metric
that you're looking at it would
in vitals, and what is
the difference between you
and that peer median.
Now the initial peer set
is recommended for you.
And this is based
on many signals.
One is the Play
Store similar apps
that you see on your
Play Store listing,
but you can go in and
edit the peer set.
We have a list of other
recommended apps for your peer
set.
You can also be able
to search for an app
by name, keyword, or
even the package name,
and then you can be able
to create the peer set.
Now, for vitals, there
are some restrictions
to how you create the peer set.
You have to have between 8
and 12 apps in the peer set.
Second is, you can only make
three changes per month,
but this still enables you to
be able to update your peer
set often enough where
there are new market
entrants, and previous
competitors, you can remove,
that you can see as
no longer competitors.
You can also only select one
app from any other developer
account, and no apps from
your own developer account.
We've been extremely
thoughtful in how
we've designed this
feature, because we value
your privacy and your data.
If you really want, you can
opt out of this program.
And if there's an
opt out functionality
within the Preferences
section of the console.
I would point out a
few things here though.
One is that your vitals
data can be measured,
oftentimes in a test lab.
And the most advanced
developers who have the budget
already do that today.
So we believe that this feature
creates more easy access
for all developers to be able to
understand the core performance
metrics that they
care about the most
from that part of the
ecosystem that matters to them.
Second is that your data is
combined with a set of at least
seven other apps, and only
the median of that peer set
is shown.
Finally, this feature is
only available to people
who have vital data and are
above the privacy threshold.
This feature is now
available, starting today,
for the performance areas in
vitals of battery, rendering,
startup time, and stability.
And, for the newest area of
the vitals performance product,
app size.
If you want to learn
more about app size,
there's a session
tomorrow just dedicated
to that product at 8:30
AM tomorrow at stage two.
So, early risers, you
got your opportunity.
We've had a few developers
using this product
over the past couple of weeks,
and they've really enjoyed it.
And we have a quote here
from the game loft team,
where they've been able to
prioritize their engineering
advancements because
they're now able to select
the specific apps that match
their particular requirements.
ADAM CARPENTER: And this is
really cool because my role,
I work with a lot of
[? FEXOs, ?] non-technical
ones, chief marketing
officers, chief product
officers, and a
lot of them don't
have the background
or the experience
to be able to understand
a lot of the really
technical nuances.
What I think is
really valuable here
is that business
leaders are going
to be able to leverage
this information
to make very important form
decisions without needing
to be an engineer.
And so that's really, really
powerful and really exciting.
But when I think about
public data like ratings,
are we going to
do anything there
to actually let
developers see it?
FERGUS HURLEY: Adam, you
might have a future career
as a fortuneteller, because you
can predict the future here.
That was meant as a joke.
OK, so for vitals,
we have some rules.
But for ratings,
because the data
is public and available
to all users when
they go to the Play Store, we
have very little restrictions
here.
You can be able to go in and
select between 1 and 12 apps
and be able to see, for
each individual app, what
their rating is, how that
compares with your rating,
and how it compares to
the median of the peer set
you create.
And then you can be able to
update this peer set that as
often as you want.
As Corina mentioned, it's
really important to understand,
when you're looking at
the trend of your data,
how you're performing
relative to the benchmark.
So for both vitals
and for ratings,
we'll show you the peer set
median plotted over time,
along with your data.
For ratings, you'll
be able to switch
between your daily rating
and your lifetime rating.
Over the past couple
of years, we've
received a lot of
feedback from developers
that the Google
Play rating that's
shown to users on
the store has issues.
One of the primary ones is
that if you had a bad release
a few years ago, you're still
suffering from that today,
because it is based on
your lifetime rating.
So we're really excited to make
available a new Google Play
rating.
This is shown to you today in
your rating section of the Play
Console.
However, it will not be
shown to users on the store
until August of this year.
So you have plenty
of time to start
working on improving your rating
and responding to your user
reviews to try and improve your
rating between now and then.
If you go to the ratings details
page for any of the breakdowns
that we have across country,
language, Android version,
et cetera, you can see
how your rating compares
with each of the breakdowns
that are there across the peer
set that you create,
and that you can
update as often as you want.
ADAM CARPENTER: So
this is really helpful,
and I think it's
actually going to provide
a lot of intelligence
to developers
about even where to prioritize
user acquisition, which
countries are strong,
which countries are not.
What kind of guidance and advice
do you have for everybody here?
FERGUS HURLEY: Yeah, so I
think the top piece of advice
here is just to
use this feature.
Oftentimes, a lot of
people within companies
don't have access
to the Play Console.
So I encourage you to make
sure that the people who
would get benefit
from this product,
to get them access
to the Play Console
and share the data as broadly as
possible with your colleagues,
so you know where you can
improve and make better data
driven decisions.
Now in terms of how to
select your peer set,
I'd recommend picking apps
that you aspire to be like,
and updating it when
the market changes.
ADAM CARPENTER: And so, all
these benchmarks and everything
are really powerful, really
insightful, really something
that I hope can provide
a lot of actionability
for you as you look at your
game or your app's performance
relative to your competitors.
And I'm really hopeful
that you guys will
be able to set targets
for future releases,
to be able to aspire
to make improvements,
and how you can actually
grow your business.
And, when I really
think about everything
we've been talking about today,
this hierarchical model, how
everything feeds together,
and all of the features
that we're adding to the
console, I really get inspired,
and I really get
excited, because things
like refreshing the
core metrics, that's
going to be significantly more
meaningful and significantly
more insightful than any of
the information we have there
today.
Additionally, just
being able to cut users
based on whether they're
new or they're returning,
it's going to help you kind
of decompose your active users
and get a sense for, how is
it growing and shrinking,
and just fundamentally how
is that audience changing
over time.
Additionally, those
change analysis charts
that Corina was talking about,
that's especially important
because, as she mentioned,
normalized metrics,
they're really the
fundamental way
that she should be
evaluating her business.
Absolute numbers, revenue, DAU,
those are the vanity metrics
and they tend to be
lacking indicators.
Normalized metrics
are more often
going to be leading
indicators that provide you
with solid science about how
your app or game is trending
prior to it impacting
your daily active users
or impacting your revenue.
And so, as I think
about all of this
and how it fits together, user
perceptions of quality, vitals,
benchmarks, it's going to
give all of you in the room,
everybody out
there in the world,
significantly more
intelligent insights
into just, what is
the user experience
like, how are they
enjoying your app or game,
and where are the biggest
opportunities for you
to actually grow?
Especially in light
of the benchmarks
that we're actually
adding to the console,
because now you're going to have
a real good understanding of,
what does good look like?
And that was always what
I had a problem with when
I was on the developer side.
What's good?
Because as much as
I knew everything
I could possibly
know about my app,
I had no idea of the
competitive landscape.
And so this is where we're
adding to the console,
to expose those competitive
insights to yourselves,
and enable you to optimize and
grow your business over time.
And so thank you all very
much for coming today.
Hope you all got
a lot out of this,
and I hope you really
get a lot of value
out of actually working
with the console.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]